[Musique]
c'est littéralement le pire week-end de
ma vie n'est banni du comic-con vie tu
te seras fait couper les cheveux par un
toiletteur je vais entrer au lycée landi
avec une coupe de chiens c'est mes deux
meilleurs amis
mon plan c'est de l'art offert le
meilleur week-end de leur vie avant
notre entrée au lycée ce lundi mais les
meilleurs souvenirs il n'est ce pas de
plan qui se déroule comme prévu ils
naissent plutôt plan qui foire
complètement tamil bazar chez moi dit
mon chien tu vois tu as pris ma vie et
hier mais faux
comment ont pu survivre au lycée si on
peut même pas survivre à ce week end
désolé si tu trouves que je suis pas
cool j'ai dit des choses que je regrette
d'avoir dit c'est la fin c'est sûr c'est
pas la fin quand on l'a pas décidé
d'accord parce que quand la situation se
complique
et c'est là qu'il faut qu'on s'applique
t pas j'ai un blanc je déteste quand tu
dis ça
m
les choses ont changé quand je suis
arrivé au lycée tulle aime d'amour au
nom dans la vie il faut parfois faire
preuve d'audace et volets de l'avant
argonautes
cette fois ce pourrait petit il va
sauter de 12 états
pour certains la situation peut paraître
insurmontable
mettons nous tous
les membres du crh coup
c'est à dire du tout
compris les gars partent il fallait que
ce soit le week-end le plus marrant de
tou tv notas des stars est là le
meilleur week-end de ma vie le meilleur
pourquoi
[Musique]